how are you doing good but how you doing
we do an excellent first Congrats on the
movie thank you
now let's compare to the real state here
we go huh governor one of the most takes
Hobbs are Shawn Wow it's that's a tough
one because the best part is is Dwayne
had a specific goal in every one of
their scenes and that was to make Jason
crack so you know there were no a the
live there was always the lines that
were scripted that we're gonna be
hilarious but then Dwayne had a specific
goal every day of what can I say that
it's just gonna mess Jason up and
Jason's tough but once you get under
there and you can really start pushing
Jason buttons he'll start cracking every
time so for that reason all I'll say
Jason cracked a little bit more but
that's because DJ was the mastermind
behind it all more likely to get it on
the first take Hobbs our show so Jason's
extremely prepared so the great thing
about Jason is he's looking at the lines
he's studying him comes in super dialed
in so I'm always gonna lean toward
Jason's that because DJ will come in and
the wind shifts a little bit the suns in
the sky certain place he's like hey you
know what I got a new idea I'm gonna put
something on its feet
hey do you want to try this nut let me
put this homage feet first brother and
then he'll drop something new and do a
little improv so I'll give this one two
days who has more hair Hobbs or sha
Oh sha for sure sha for sure Hobbs is as
aerodynamically smooth less faster at
learning their lines
Hobbs our Shawn I will say that Hobbs is
the fastest in the industry of learning
as wise and I'll say simply because
wrestling as you know gigantic
monologues 20 minutes before you got to
go in front of 80,000 people bring it to
DJ looks it over amazing to watch him
gobble it all up one take live in front
of 90,000 people so I will put online
nobody in Hollywood will learn lines
faster than dwayne johnson who is faster
at leaving their trailer hobbs our shaw
mmm I'm gonna say leaving the trailer
faster Jason is a little faster but
that's just because Hobbs is enormous
the wind resistance just naturally slows
you that it's hard to get the shoulders
out the door wins in a fight
Hobson Shaw or Jason Bourne oh it's I
mean look they're all part of the
universal family as we like to say but
Jason Bourne lost the minute you
mentioned his name there's just it's
it's not even a competition the wins in
a fight between Hobbes and Shaw and
Deadpool we'll see that's tough because
now you're bringing in you're bringing
in a mutant healing factor
uncharacteristically superhuman
abilities in Deadpool so now while I
like to think that we've made Hobbs a
bit superhuman in our movies we always
increase his abilities it's gonna be
pretty hard to beat a guy that all he
needs is a piece of flesh to regenerate
this whole body except that uh who wins
in a fight Hobbes and Shaw or rocky with
the rocky theme music plan the only
reason I will say Hobbes and Shaw will
win for sure is because there's a level
of subtext because Hobbes is actually
rocky from birth so it's where one guy
is rocky in character the actual guy
playing Hobbes is actually rocky so once
you start to do the math it's no
competition but the ones in a fight a
Hobbes in Shaw or the predator oh yeah
Hobson Sean Hobson sharp because it's a
to look Arnold took down the predator by
himself with some jungle stuff and a
machete Hobbes and Shaw it's the two of
them Hobbes is as big if not bigger then
Arnold at the time and then we have a
McLaren thrown in as well I'll I'll go
Hobson show who wins Hobson Shaw or John
McClain again Hobbs and Chau buddy is no
competition to verse 1 to verse 1 ok
Hobbes in Shaw or John wick that's
pretty good it's pretty good but again I
will say if you're not if you don't have
like a mutant X Factor in your blood or
something like that's gonna be pretty
hard to overcome Hobbs I'm shocked
speaking of an X Factor who wins in a
fight pubs in Shaw or Chev Chelios from
crank
it is he cranked up oh yeah I'm gonna
say that's gonna come to a bloody
shockingly scary draw okay I got to draw
winds and a fight Hobson Shaw or Bruce
Lee it's got that inch punch right it's
got that mean but he is human and Hobbes
it's not and and Shaw is unbelievably
angry so that the combination that once
again I give it to our boys Hobbes and
Shaw or Ripley in aliens okay on this
one on this one she overcame a species
just engineered for destruction and were
gentlemen so Ripley definitely takes a
winner I finally got my boy let's see if
I can go to number two
yeah dogs in Shaw or Sarah Connor in
Terminator 2 again we're gentlemen and
Sarah Connor has dealt with cyborgs so
just slightly but she'll she'll take the
win because she'll probably beat Shaw
and then Hobbes will be carrying Shaw
out of the scene and then that hit with
his back turned she will do something
that will pretty much end up I thank you
for indulging me real quick and some
other stuff yeah it seems like Dwayne
has like the next year or two figure it
out what's actually coming up for you
guys that you're super excited about
yeah we're we're very fortunate we have
a great slate coming up and so the next
the first thing we have coming up after
we do a little bit of press as Comanches
coming out this December and then in
January we get into red notice red
notice which is unbelievably exciting we
got Ryan Reynolds the gal gadot bring in
rawson thurber back a big comedy action
heist thriller that is globe-trotting so
we're really thrilled with that we just
set that up at Netflix and then sometime
later that year the way it's looking is
we have a little something called Black
Adam that is uh coming up that's where I
was gonna ask you about did the I'm all
of us have been waiting for this movie
you and me both right so is it for sure
that it's going next year with the
success of Shazam it is uh well
definitely the success of Shazam
was awesome to us
it was important for us to launch that
get that into the world and just begin
crafting this universe you know it's a
big thing for us to start to create this
universe as DC section of the universe
that we're working on with characters we
have planned to bring into it headline
by Shazam black atom but yeah the idea
is is if everything falls in line right
now joma joma klutz era he just closed
this deal which we're very excited about
and you know the plan is to be filming
that end of a next year